remember I said to you before I had a
theory as to why we don't call this
reverse Proctor
okay my theory is because this process
is actually useful for things that you
wouldn't ordinarily call product the
example now this is interesting to me I
mean for you this is a very simple
function right why haven't we let the
result for this earlier okay and the
answer is because really you're needing
to match my parts to do it okay now I'm
gonna say it's using exactly the same
method like so so what would you choose
so I'll stick a 1 in there just think I
wanted it so now what am I going to pick
for my different components you equals
what is that gonna work out for you
why is that a bad way to go okay so when
you go from here to here it becomes zero
and the thing breaks down right because
you're gonna integrate the part of these
it's just gonna explode on you so
instead I'm gonna choose log X it's not
like it's hard to differentiate right so
do you
IQ see Dad right so now going all the
way around the box that's what the I'm
left with so what's V it's just X isn't
it okay let's see how you going okay
when I start with the product here right
so read down left-hand column X log X
okay what do I subtract V do u BD u X
times whatever X DX well that's
convenient right X log X this of course
the integral of one so you just get
minus X plus u caustic is now I'm
finished
okay so yes very simple function but it
means this to really see what's going on